أجنبي
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [موسيقى] [
موسيقى] أجنبي [موسيقى] أجنبي
أوروبا
تفتقر إلى وسائل أجنبية أجنبية أجنبية أجنبية أجنبية [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أجنبية
أجنبية أجنبية
ألبانيا هي دراسة حالة لأوروبا
لأن ألبانيا تنتج 100
منتج متجدد  الطاقة لذلك لم يكن لدينا أي
مشكلة مع الغاز الروسي ولكن
من ناحية أخرى، حتى إنتاج 100
طاقة متجددة نتعرض لها في
السوق الدولية للطاقة لأننا
ملزمون باستيراد حوالي 20
بالمائة من احتياجات البلاد خلال فترة
2022 الحكومة الألبانية
والشركة أن الشركات الوطنية التي
تقدم الطاقة في البلاد
أنفقت حوالي نصف مليار
يورو فقط لتوفير الطاقة
لمواطننا لأننا اتخذنا قرارًا جريئًا للغاية
لحماية جميع الأسر
والصغيرة  الشركات في ألبانيا من
أزمة الطاقة هذه،
لدينا هدف قوي للغاية
نريد تحقيقه بحلول عام 2030 لزيادة
طاقتنا الإنتاجية بأربعة تيرابايت
من خلال تحويل ألبانيا من بلد مستورد صافي
إلى بلد مصدر صافي كما
قلت في لوحتي لـ  بالنسبة لنا، من
المهم جدًا إنشاء
مزيج مستدام من الطاقة
يعتمد فقط على إنتاج الطاقة المتجددة، وهو ما
يبدو أمرًا عصريًا للغاية ولكن من ناحية أخرى،
يجب أن يكون لدينا أمن الطاقة
لبلدنا ولهذا السبب
نعمل على مشروع جديد يتضمن
إنتاج  الطاقة من خلال FSRU
في جنوب ألبانيا وعلى أساس
إمدادات الغاز الطبيعي المسال، لذلك سيكون هدفنا قابلاً
للوصول بالطبع إذا وصلنا إلى هذا
النوع من خليط الإنتاج،
فالأمر المهم للغاية والذي
أعتقد أنه سيكون مفتاح النجاح
هو  التآزر بين استثمار
القطاع الحكومي وقطاع الدولة
والقطاع الخاص فقط لأعطيكم
مثال بسيط خلال عام 2022 من خلال وجود
هذا الوضع في كل أوروبا كان لدينا
حوالي
1.7 جيجا من الاستثمار من
القطاع الخاص في الطاقة المتجددة
بالطبع و  كان الحقن في
الاقتصاد يعادل
1.1 مليار يورو لدولة صغيرة
مثل ألبانيا لأنني أعتقد أنك
تعلم أن ألبانيا دولة صغيرة
لديها ثلاثة ملايين من الأدلة وهذا
استثمار مهم للغاية ومن خلال
التنسيق وإنشاء هذا النوع من
التآزر بين القطاعات نعتقد
أنه في المستقبل سيصل هذا الاستثمار إلى
أكثر من 20 مليار يورو حتى عام
2230 وهو هدفنا المستهدف أن نكون ثريين،
إنه معقد للغاية الآن، هذا هو
الوضع، إنه ليس مرتبطًا فقط
بأزمة الطاقة، لدينا أزمة  التي تأتي
من الطمع ثم الطمع بعد ذلك وكان
كل شيء مرتبطًا بارتفاع
الأسعار بسبب الطلبات الكبيرة
على الطلب الزائد في السوق،
لذلك لا يتعلق الأمر بالمعادن فقط، بل
يتعلق بهذا الطلب الرهيب من
السوق للحصول على المزيد من بناء الطاقة الكهروضوئية
المتنزهات المزيد من بناء المتنزهات المائية
بالطبع أثرت على الوضع
والقطاع ولكن من ناحية أخرى، فإن
الأسعار المطبقة على بيع
الطاقة جذابة جدًا
للشركات حتى تتمكن من موازنة هذه
الأسعار المرتفعة للمواد الخام،
وسيكون عام 2023  دعنا نقول عامًا حاسمًا
فيما يتعلق
باستدامة
القطاع لأنه خلال عام 2022 لا يمكنك
الاعتماد بأي شكل من الأشكال على أي أرقام لأنه
كان عامًا مجنونًا للطاقة بالنسبة
لأوروبا ولكل العالم. [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
الوبادة الأوروبية
أجنبية أجنبية
هناك بعض الدعم للطلب على الطاقة
نظرًا لأن الصين أسرع في
إعادة فتحها وأسرع، لذلك هناك
قوتان متعارضتان مختلفتان في مكانهما
جيدًا، من الصعب التحدث عن الفائزين في
سياق الحرب ولكن إذا كان الأمر كذلك، إذا
كنا نركز فقط  فيما يتعلق بالطاقة،
كانت الولايات المتحدة تفضل بسبب
ذلك أي منتج للطاقة
ليس روسيا على الأقل المفضلة بسبب
ارتفاع الأسعار، وبالتالي فإن
صادرات المطارات أكثر قيمة في الوقت الحالي
ولكن من الواضح أن أوروبا تبتعد عن
روسيا والوقود الأحفوري.  الوقود وتم تسليط الضوء عليه للاندفاع
للعثور على موردين آخرين
رأوه في الولايات المتحدة مثل شريك جيد
في الولايات المتحدة، وقد رأوا مثل
العملاء الجيدين في بلدانكم الأوروبية،
كما أن صادرات الولايات المتحدة تتزايد
بشكل كبير لأنها تسد
الفجوة التي تقدمها روسيا  حسنًا أجنبيًا
الحرب في أوكرانيا وخاصة
إمدادات الوقود الأحفوري الروسي نحو أوروبا أو أه
سلطت الضوء على أمن الطاقة
مرة أخرى لذلك كان هناك
إعادة توظيف من سياسة الطاقة أو
سياسة الطاقة من انتقال الطاقة
إلى أمن الطاقة  خلال عام 2022
ورأينا العديد من الدول أه مثل ألمانيا
أو دول أخرى في الاتحاد الأوروبي
تستثمر بكثافة في
البنية التحتية للوقود الأحفوري وخاصة في القدرة على استيراد الغاز الطبيعي المسال
بسبب قضية أمن الطاقة
لذلك أصبح أمن الطاقة الآن تحت
الأضواء على
الجميع في العالم كل كل
صانع السياسات لأنه وضع مثل
تسليط الضوء على عدم الأمان، وهو أمر لا يمكن ضمانه،
لذلك فإننا نشهد
جهدًا متجددًا بشأن أمن الطاقة، وهذا
لا يعني أن البلدان لا
تفكر في التحول في مجال الطاقة، ونحن
نؤمن بذلك  في الواقع،
سوف يتسارع الوضع الحالي هناك
كتحول على المدى المتوسط ​​والطويل،
وخاصة لأن العديد من الحكومات ترى
الآن التجديدات ليس فقط
كوسيلة
للحصول على بيئة أفضل ولكن أيضًا
كوسيلة لفرض
أمن الطاقة لأنها  إعادة
إنتاج الموارد التلقائية محليًا أثناء ذلك
لا تحتاج إلى استيراد
بعض أو الفوز، مرحبًا
بالبنية التحتية موجودة
وستظل روسيا كمنتج مهم
للغاز على المدى الطويل
على الرغم من الإنتاج، فسوف نتراجع والبنية
التحتية موجودة ونحن كذلك  هل هذه
ليست توقعاتنا الأساسية ولكن إذا فكرنا
في تغيير المنطقة في
روسيا والدول الأوروبية التي تحاول
دعم هذا النظام الجديد وبالطبع
يمكننا أن نرى تصدير مثل جهاز الاستقبال
من روسيا إلى الولايات المتحدة إلى
الاتحاد الأوروبي  الاستئناف لأن
خطوط الأنابيب موجودة تمامًا ولكننا
لا نتوقع أن يحدث ذلك في
النسخة القصيرة من البئر
الأجنبية،
فهناك الكثير من الاستثمار بحاجة إلى
إجابة أخرى قصيرة حقًا ونحن
نحترم التجديد مثل المزيد من الاستثمار
نعم بالطبع في مصادر الطاقة المتجددة خاصة
من الدول الأوروبية ولكننا
نتوقع أيضًا المزيد من الاستثمار في إنتاج الوقود الأحفوري
وهذا ليس فقط أه
لأنه هناك حاجة
لموازنة الطلب على العرض ولكن أيضًا
لأن الأسعار على الأقل
مرتفعة في الوقت الحالي حتى  على الرغم من
انخفاضها عن ارتفاعات عام 2022، إلا أنها
تظل مرتفعة والأسعار المرتفعة
يتم دفعها دائمًا لمزيد من
الاستثمار في الوقود الأحفوري، ونتوقع أن
يستمر سوق النفط والغاز قصيرًا أو
مستمرًا جدًا جدًا
من عام 2025 على الأقل، وذلك
سيدعم بالطبع الاستثمار في
إعادة إنتاج الوقود الأحفوري،
فنحن نرى مثل السوق العالمية نوعًا ما
مثل الانقسام إلى معسكرين، أحدهما
دول ستستمر في تلقي
الواردات الروسية أه وكأننا نواصل
الاستيراد من روسيا، وسأزيد حتى
الاستيراد من
روسيا هو بشكل أساسي الصين والهند
لأنهم سيحصلون على نتائج إيجابية رخيصة جدًا
منهم ثم
الدول الأخرى التي تبتعد عن
روسيا وستركز أكثر على
الولايات المتحدة
كمورد عالمي وهذا يشبه بشكل
أساسي  أوروبا وأنا
لن أسميها مثل التنافس بين
هذين المعسكرين بالطبع إنه
صراع بين روسيا والاتحاد الأوروبي
والولايات المتحدة ولكني لن أسميه
نهرًا بين أوروبا والصين
ولكن هذا هم  سوف أفعل ذلك تمامًا كما أعني أن
الصين ستفعل ما هو أفضل
بالنسبة للتمويل أو سأحاول الحصول على
وقود أحفوري رخيص من روسيا بينما
سيتعين على أوروبا أن تتمكن من
اقتصادها بشكل أسرع تمامًا مثل محاولة
الابتعاد عن Securus بشكل عام
والاعتماد بشكل أكبر على الولايات المتحدة كمورد للطاقة،
لا يمكنك الاعتماد على مورد واحد
لمعظم واردات الوقود الأحفوري الخاصة بك،
وهذا مهم للغاية
لأنه درس تتعلمه الصين أيضًا
وتولي الكثير من الاهتمام، كما
ترى الصين  بالطبع تحاول
الحصول على المزيد من الغاز من النفط من روسيا ولكن
كل روسيا والصين الأخرى تحاول أيضًا
تنويع إمداداتها من خلال
زيادة الاستثمار في آسيا الوسطى،
فهناك خط أنابيب جديد تم الإعلان عنه
مع ترمستان ولذا نعتقد أن
هذا
سيجعل الأمر كذلك.  الحكومات تكون أكثر وعيًا بمخاطر
الاعتماد أكثر من اللازم على أحد
موردي الطاقة، وسوف أه
درس آخر سيكون محاولة إنتاج
المزيد محليًا وأنا لا أتحدث
عن النفط والغاز، لذلك أتحدث فقط
عن ذلك الأكثر طاقة متجددة  لذلك سنرى
الآن أن التجديدات يتم النظر فيها كوسيلة
لتعزيز أه أمن الطاقة والدرس
الثالث هو أهمية كفاءة الطاقة.
في العديد من الدول الأوروبية لم
تكن طموحة للغاية بشأن كفاءة الطاقة
وما شابه ذلك في السنوات العشر الماضية و  الآن
نرى عواقب الحياة عندما
تحتاج إلى تقليل الاستهلاك لأنه
ليس لديك المورد لأن
الأسعار باهظة للغاية وهم
يواجهون بعض الصراعات
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
شكرًا أجنبية [
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك